here in Spanish Wells brought gloves
phishing is a way of life this is what
we do to earn a living if you abuse it
you'll lose it and so we try our best to
pass on to the next generation of
fishermen that come along relaxers been
sourcing rock lobster from the Bahamian
Spanish Wells community for over thirty
years because of our size and scale we
can use our influence to drive change so
we partnered with worldwide Life Fund to
support fishery improvement projects in
the Caribbean one of the key goals of
our fishery improvement project is to
ensure that there is a healthy
population of lobster and that helps
fishermen as well because it's securing
their livelihood for the long term my
name is Chuck bender and I'm a seventh
generation fisherman with my sons
becoming the next generation
I've been a seaman my whole life no one
gives us the paycheck our entire
livelihood is based on what's there for
us and what we get with our own hands
so the fishery Improvement Project has
really created a system of checks and
balances regulations are put in place to
ensure that the lobster population can
continue to reproduce and thrive here in
the Bahamas the legal link to harvest
rock lobster is five and a half inches
we put the tail of the rock lobster next
to the measuring stick if it falls
within the length of the handle it's the
legal size tail to be harvest very
important that we leave those that are
undersized and egg bearing for them to
grow and to breed and to spawn I noticed
that one of them look kind of borderline
I think we need Jake the van in short so
yeah you're just gonna let her go
you want it for tomorrow this is the way
you need to do it so the Bahamas has
some other regulations in place for the
rock lobster fishery
there's the closed season that's put
into place and that's to allow time for
the lobster population to grow here in
the Bahamas the rock lobster season is
from August 1st until March 31st during
those months in the offseason the rock
lobster spawning my nephew is Thomas
hinder the son of chop bender and
together they are two of the most
sustainable fishermen on Spanish words
ribbon supply and Red Lobster with
lobster for 34 years the darker the tail
the deeper economic we've been able to
sustain the fishing industry and grow it
tremendously the Bahamian rock lobster
fishery is an exemplary fishery World
Wildlife Fund is working with Red
Lobster to help improve fisheries and
other areas as well in the Caribbean in
South America and an other fisheries
similar to the Bahamas
they actually more rock lobster here now
than what there were 30 years ago as
long as we practice these sustainable
ways of harvesting there will be a
future for rock lobster fishing
[Music]